ça y est après trois ans et demi de long
est âpre débat de tourmente politique
le royaume uni ne fait plus partie de
l'union européenne
[Musique]
l'horloge de big ben n'a pas sonné pour
marquer le coup mais little bay était là
pour souligner l'événement historique
avec grand bruit
[Musique]
alors que l'horloge de downing street
des comptes est encore une heure avant
que le bric site ne prenne effet le
premier ministre boris johnson s'est
adressé à la nation des six domaines
dont mme bricq soc 15 ans on a une loi
bachelot
chez ses opposants brigitte les
vénéneuse les sentiments étaient
partagés entre tristesse amertume et
colère
[Musique]
c'est le cas pour siemens qui vient ici
devant parlement d'une à quatre fois par
semaine pour affirmer son désir de voir
le royaume uni est resté au sein d'union
européenne depuis 2016 c'est plus qu'un
pacte économique disparaît dit il c'est
tout un projet de paix joe magri
je suis fâché 10 1 me les politiciens
ont été très divisé et du côté du brics
dit à tout le moins ils n'ont aucune
notion de la vérité et ils ne
comprennent pas les conséquences de ce
pourquoi ils ont fait campagne
ça me choque
il ne peut plus rien contre l'inévitable
mais ils continueront de manifester pour
se rappeler au gouvernement qui a
maintenant un nom pour négocier les
modalités du brésil pour les trois
millions cinq cent mille européen est
allé outre manche les implications du
brésil au niveau personnel et la
dimension politique du divorce avec les
27 pays européens sont une source d
angoisse qu on cherche un peu à oublier
dans ce pop ce soir c'est européens
doivent maintenant obtenir le cndd
status un statut de résident permanent
auprès de l'administration britannique
n'escomptent il pour autant à l'abri
d'une injustice nicolas at-on un
français et le président de deux primés
lienne un organisme qui se consacre
entièrement à la défense des droits
d'euro p1 du royaume uni le brésil c'est
un peu une célébration crimi nation
autres les noms britanniques et on le
ressent au quotidien c'est les regards à
temps ils entendent un accent à fait
différent bah c'est le fait qu'on doit
on doit faire une demande de statut pour
rester chez nous
[Musique]
oh
et